good morning believe nation today's
message is love what you do over you
Justin Bieber my love and my passion is
people and that's where my music comes
is because I'm able to give them
something special whether they're going
through whatever they're going through I
think the the connection comes through
my music and helping them through my
music I don't know if necessarily I
meant to be a public speaker or someone
who's you know I think what my platform
is is come to my show
feel the energy for my music know that
my music is positive and in light and
beautiful and and yeah and hopefully
they can take something from that
because I think that when it's almost
like a religion in itself you know when
you're coming to a concert you're you're
leaving all your troubles behind you're
going to just be like completely
enveloped in the music and you have your
hands up and it's like you're just there
and you're present and I think that
what's so beautiful about that is like
everyone's connected everyone's there
and and and they're for the right
reasons and that that's why I love what
I do
so what do you think you know for so
many creative people whether they're
entrepreneurs or whether they're artists
I think there's this juxtaposition right
do we chase money or do we love what we
do when we are committed to doing like
the one single act when we find what
that is for us our own artistry you know
for entrepreneurs that's solving
problems right for people they have to
you know write you know for Justin maybe
it's they have to express themselves
musically and so when people say love
what you do it's it's really about
figuring out who you are to me it's
about figuring out who you are how do
you tap into that artistry and then
figuring out ways of building your life
around that artistry that's kind of the
first thoughts that kind of popped in my
head
I love it I think too as I watched you
watch Justin talking about a concert you
can feel the just like he gets lost in
it
I think that's what you need to find and
you'll love what you do as a way of
saying that where you want to find the
thing that you can just get lost in and
it becomes this religious experience any
talks about the hours can float by that
you forget the rest of the world and all
the chaos and all the crap about running
the business and just do your thing
whatever that thing is finding it and if
you don't know it didn't explore until
you find it and then try to spend as
much time there as possible because
that's the thing you're gonna be able to
have the most impact with make the most
money with you know be the happiest in
and so if you haven't found it yet then
I encourage you to explore explore
explore until you find it it's also if I
can just add on one last thing it's the
most natural thing that you can do right
and a lot of people try different roles
you know they maybe they'll get a job
and they want to be this person or their
parents told them they got to be this
person and I think it's really about
stopping to resist who you really are
and almost kind of like going into it
right just getting lost into just like
you're in a concert or you're listening
to great music or you know you're you're
doing that thing that just gives you joy
that's it's like what comes natural to
you and so it's like stop fighting it
right and and kind of embrace that so
the question of the day today is what do
you naturally enjoy doing I like it
leave it down the comments below we're
gonna join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and we'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another expensive
let's pray so give me go